je vous propose à présent de prendre la
direction de saint malo pour y retrouver
le skipper louis burton bonjour bonjour
alors on le rappelle vous êtes
originaire de rambouillet mais vous avez
choisi de passer ce confinement en
famille en bretagne alors ma première
question comment ça se passe ça se passe
bien j'ai quitté rambouillet il ya
quelques années déjà et en effet on est
installé à saint malo on a la chance
d'avoir une maison un peu dans la
campagne donc c'est plutôt agréable pour
les enfants ils peuvent aller courir et
donc on est un peu privilégiés par
rapport à ça est-ce que vous avez un
planning type chaque jour oui en fait
depuis trois semaines on a réouvert
l'entreprise donc on essaye de ne pas
être plus de deux personnes à la fois
dans l'atelier de préparation de bureau
vallée du bateau chacun met des masques
et puis on fait une rotation toutes les
semaines voilà donc moi je vais au
bureau maintenant tous les jours et puis
à la maison on fait des courses une fois
par semaine quand y avait école mais les
petits bretons la sai et des slovaques
hausse mais quand il y avait école on
faisait l'école le matin et puis l'après
midi plutôt ludique est libre et voilà
et on fait beaucoup beaucoup à manger on
fait beaucoup de repas
oui comme tous les français j'ai envie
de dire voilà les français qui se sont
découvert une passion pour la cuisine
pendant ce confinement
donc c'est votre cas aussi alors vous
parlez de réouverture de votre
entreprise justement vous devez
participer à la prochaine édition du
vendée globe
vous savez si c'est alors c'est en
novembre prochain donc il ya encore
quelques mois vous savez si s'est
maintenu alors oui on travaille beaucoup
en fait aux avec l'organisateur de la
course
donc depuis les dernières annonces du
président de la république
l'organisateur donc la région vendée a
communiqué la semaine dernière pour dire
que sauf mention sanitaire contraire le
vendée globe serait maintenu il y aura
un village parce que c'est une grande
fête populaire le vendée globe et donc
il y aura bien un village alors ce sera
peut-être un village
des mesures sanitaires adaptés en
fonction de warnes et la pandémie mais
la course sera bien lieu donc tous les
projets on est une trentaine de bateaux
normalement ces lignes à cette course va
essayer de s'organiser pour être prêt à
aller naviguer dès qu'on aura à nouveau
l'autorisation du coup c'est par rapport
à cette situation vous avez pris un
petit peu de retard j'imagine pour cette
préparation retard que vous allez sans
doute rattrapé
oui en fait c'est sûr qu'on est là on
devait mettre normalement bureau vallée
à l'eau on va avoir peut-être par
rapport à notre planning un mois de
retard on espère pouvoir mettre à l'eau
en fête le 15 mai au lieu du 15 avril
c'est sûr que du coup l'été va être va
pas être trop reposant on va pas pouvoir
trop partir en vacances je pense et on
devrait réussir à rattraper le temps
perdu en mettant à profit les mois d'été
où on va essayer de maintenir une
activité à 100% alors que c'est plutôt
une période habituellement ou où
l'équipe par an par congé
alternativement donc voilà je pense que
si on reste dans ce dans ce time in las
de déconfinement on devrait être capable
de s'aligner au départ du vendée globe
dans de bonnes conditions
alors pour vous qu'est-ce qui est le
plus compliqué dans ce confinement le
manque de la mer j'imagine alors c'est
sûr que d'un point de vue personnel le
fait de ne pas pouvoir aller en mer
autant qu'on veut
bon c'était compliqué parce que c'est
c'est vrai que l'on a la chance de vivre
de notre passion et puis on est on est
là pour ça on adore ça moi j'adore ça
donc c'est un peu compliqué après non ce
qui est ce qu est ce qui a été le plus
difficile à gérer mais je pense comme
tous les tous les chefs d'entreprise et
tous les français c'est de ne pas
vraiment savoir de quoi
le lendemain va être fait de quelle
manière on va pouvoir retrouver une vie
à peu près normale
voilà c'est sûr que cette cette phase on
n'est pas habitué à ça ou en fait même
les mêmes nos dirigeants etc ne savent
pas exactement comment les choses vont
se passer
le vrai du faux style effect news les
bonnes news etc
donc voilà il ya tout un travail
intellectuel et psychologique qu'il faut
arriver à faire
justement vous parlez de psychologie
alors vous avez l'habitude évidemment
d'être d'être confinés dans un espace
réduit et ce que les skippers finalement
sont mieux armés pour pour vivre ce
confinement
non je pense qu'on a on a quelques on a
quelques habitudes qui font que on se
sent peut-être moins empressées que que
des personnes qui n'ont jamais connu ça
personnellement ça se passe bien je
pense que pour pas mal de skippers du
vendée globe c'est une période qui se
passe bien parce que c'est vrai que on a
l'habitude sur un tour du monde de
partir pendant trois mois tout seul de
dette dans des surfaces de vie qui sont
très restreintes
donc on est on est parmi les mieux armés
en effet pour traverser cette période
est ce que vous pourriez partage est
justement de trois conseils pour les
téléspectateurs de tv 78 pour mieux
vivre ce confinement
bon je pense que c'est un peu commencé
un peu comme en vélo quand on attaque
une cote difficile il faut plutôt
regarder devant sa roue et par regarder
tant de la montagne
il faut avancer au jour le jour il faut
garder dans un coin de sa tête a laissé
à terre où les choses qu'on avait prévu
de faire du confinement actuelle partir
en vacances voyages etc et et garder ça
dans un coin de sa tête quand même un
peu un rêve comme quelque chose qu'on
souhaite retrouver
et puis avancer avancer pas à pas pour
pas que pour pas que la pente paraître
paraît trop difficile je pense qu'il
faut ensuite beaucoup lire comme
beaucoup s'informer continuer à débattre
avec ses proches
et puis essayer de positiver en
réfléchissant aux conséquences positives
corps à ce confinement sur notre avenir
immédiat et notre avenir à plus ou moins
long terme merci louis burton en tout
cas pour ses conseils et bon courage
pour la suite mais retire aux parois